so what did dallas keiko have in store
for game number two against the pirates
after an eight-inning gem friday at the
cubs
[Applause]
and while it took one pitch today
to do what the pirates could not do all
of yesterday two and two
there's the swing of the miss for strike
three on a slider from dallas kykel in
his first strikeout three and two from
kykel
and he struck him out
change up ends the inning trevor 1-4 the
era very respectable
3.7 see if he could be a little more
efficient
there's a ground ball to the right side
that change up and eric gonzalez on the
right side throws him out three williams
with an eight pitch inning
strikeout number three in a row for
dallas kykel
3-2 got him looking strike three calling
on the inside corner that is four
straight strikeouts here for dallas
kykel
fair ball nice jump cb down the line
to avoid a laser from edwin
and runners are at second and third
well a chance for luis robert
and robert hits one of the air to right
center field tracking that one out as
tucker he'll make the catch tagging from
third on his way to the plate will be
eloy jimenez the throw will be cut off
and the white sox have taken a
one-nothing lead and here's nomar masara
[Applause]
and the indians there's a launch to left
center field by mazzara into the
alleyway
and nomar
has himself an rbi and karnazione scores
and it's two nothing
here's danny mendick second baseman 1-1
for
danny in the air right field well hit
polanco back at the wall
it's out of here
it pinballed around and danny mendick
does get it over the outstretched glove
four nothing sucks this is a slider that
doesn't slide
he takes it opposite way we told you if
you get it up in the air today it's
trouble
polanco has this in the glove just
briefly
he's very tall his timing is good
unfortunately when he hits the wall with
his elbow the glove bends back and drops
into the bullpen
encarnacion with a double and a run
scored in the four run second inning
there's a high fly ball into deep left
field reynolds will turn and watch this
one sail out of here
and carnacion
leads off the fourth inning with his
fifth home run of the year and makes it
five nothing white sox
[Applause]
swing and
[Applause]
that's a strikeout that's number six
back to the mound dallas keiko fuels it
well
and ends the innings here's elon jimenez
batting with first and third and two
outs
now the 1-1 pitch hilo hits it in the
air to right field pretty well tagged
polanco going back track wall leaping
gone
eloy jimenez opposite field another two
run blast for jimenez he's in double
digits now with ten and the white sox
have increased their lead
to eight nothing the bases are loaded
for the pirates here in the sixth
the starlings ropes one into center
that'll play to pair of pirates and
they're on the board in chicago
[Applause]
second base danny mendick
throws him out in the innings over i
believe that's going to be it for dallas
kykel he'll depart this game giving up
the two runs on just four hits but three
walks
in the sixth inning and
pittsburgh still six down in this one
jose is over three
and jose jams out to left field backing
up now reynolds still chasing and that
ball is going to fall at the top of the
wall and gone that's a home run and jose
abreu has hit his 12th and the white sox
reached double digits it's 10 to 2.
roped out to left
and that's gone a home run for eric
gonzalez a line drive
and the pirates get the second home run
from eric gonzalez this year slider
spinning
stayed on the inside part of the plate
grandahl wanted it away
steve c
on for the 13th time three outs to get
seven runs to protect
[Applause]
strike three and one gone
right hand side danny mendick
palmer today and finishes the deal a
mini sweep of the pirates
with history attached the sox win this
one in a big way ten to three
and go to 19 and 12 and just a game back
of first place minnesota the sox have
outscored opponents 32-4.